Yeah.
That's.
Thank you. That's wonderful.
We're taping at the blue building.
And the guest of honor tonight is
Yascha Mounk, who is a Johns Hopkins
professor. Give a big hand for
him.
And he's he's also the
founder of a really interesting
online platform magazine
called Persuasion.
And his latest book is The
Identity Trap, A Story
of Ideas and Power in
Our Time. And I don't know if
anybody out there is an academic
or an intellectual.
A couple people, you know,
mildly raising their hands.
One thing that's great about this
book is that if you believe in
ideas, he really
demonstrates and documents that they
matter, which is kind of nice to
hear, right.
You should hope so, for sometimes
perhaps it would be better if ideas
mattered less than they do.
That's right. Okay, but, Yascha
Mounk, thanks for coming
out. And let's start.
Give me the elevator pitch
of The Identity
Trap.
Well, the elevator pitch is that,
you know, there's a new set of ideas
about race, gender and sexual
orientation that has become
really influential over the last
decade.
And in the public debate about
it, I think there's this weird
tension where
on the right there's sometimes
attacked as
destroying everything that's good
and holy.
And sometimes people invoke terms
like woke or critical race theory to
talk about sensible things like
recognizing. But there's still
discrimination and sexism and racism
in our society, or wanting
to teach kids about the history of
injustices in United States like
slavery.
And then on on, on the left and
the mainstream. Among many of my
friends and colleagues in response
to sort of suggestion that there's
really nothing to see here,
that certainly to say you're woke is
just to,
you know, be nice and sensible
and want to see reality.
And there's really, you know,
the claim that the norms
that organizations are run by the
United States have changed is
just... it's just wrong.
And there's nothing ideologically
new about what's happening
on the left. And so what I tried to
set out to do in this book is to
actually understand what I think
is a genuinely novel ideology.
An ideology may
have intellectual history of its own
that arose in
universities in the United States
and other countries, and that then
through a series of interesting
mechanisms, came to have
this powerful influence in our
society. And I think that those
ideas deserve to be taken seriously
and then critiqued.
And so that's what I do.
On the first part of the book, I
tell the story of where these ideas
come from in the academy.
Let's start with that.
You call this new
set of ideas that have
power, that have, you know, kind of
taken over by your
telling and I think by many
people's, you know, certainly the
c-suites of certain types of
corporations, certainly the academy,
increasingly different parts of
American life.
You call that the identity
synthesis.
Can you describe what is the
identity synthesis?
Yeah. So first of all, we just need
a damn term to refer to this
ideology.
You know, like, and you're.
You don't want to say either
wokeness.
Or political correctness, I think,
Oh, yeah, all of those terms.
But we have just very politically
charged. Right?
So socialism.
Some people love socialism,
but most people in this room don't
like socialism.
But we can all agree to call it
socialism.
Right.
We need a term so we can discuss
in a serious and neutral wave as
body of ideas.
And woke is not going to do it
because it makes you sound like
you're an old man shouting at the
clouds.
Okay.
So I call it
identity synthesis.
Your ageist. I'm ageist.
Yes.
Okay.
I confess.
That's a dangerous place to be in
contemporary America.
Last time I checked, you
know, the don't trust anybody under
80 seems to be the common thing.
Long list of gerontocracy.
So? So I think, look, these ideas
are fundamentally concerned
with the role that group identities
do and should play in
our society.
And they are a synthesis of
different intellectual influences,
in particular postmodernism,
postcolonialism and critical
race theory. And so that's why I
call it the identity synthesis.
Call it whatever you want to.
Call it the thing.
If we can just have a word that
allows us to have a serious
conversation.
Let's start with those kind of
three tributaries.